Jean Zigler, bonsoir.
Bonsoir. Merci de l'invitation. Nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Voilà, je suis euh citoyen de la
République de Genève en Suisse. Je suis
euh sociologue d'origine, actuellement
vice-président du comité consultatif du
conseil des droits de l'homme. Je suis
conseiller du droits de l'homme. Avant,
pendant 8 ans, j'ai été rapporteur
spécial pour le droit à l'alimentation
des Nations- Unies. J'ai écrit des
livres qui sont mes armes de lutte. Le
dernier, c'est l'espos honte de
l'Europe. La honte de l'Europe.
J'essaie
d'utiliser les privilèges incroyables
qui sont les miens. Je suis blanc, je
suis bien nourri, je je suis citoyen
d'un pays qui est relativement corrompu
la Suisse, mais qui où les droits de
l'homme et les libertés citoyennes sont
garanties. J'ai accès aux grands médias
comme Sclevw.
Euh donc je peux m'exprimer, j'ai des
privilèges incroyables et si j'utilisais
pas ces privilèges pour lutter pour ceux
qui meurent dans la nuit, qui sont
massacrés par millions sur cette
planète, tous les 5 secondes d'enfants
dessous de 10 ans meurent de faim sur
cette planète qui déborte richesse si je
n'utilisais pas ces privilèges que j'ai
qui sont exceptionnels et qui sont dus
au hasard de la naissance, pas mon
mérite hasard de la naissance, je ne
pourrais plus me
dans le dans ce miroir. Donc aussi
longtemps Victor Hugo a dit je suis
[rires]
Victor Hugo a dit une chose formidable
et puis après je me tais dit une chose
formidable je suis vieux évidemment
formidable dit je veux mourir vivant et
bien moi je veux mourir vivant en
combattant pour ceux qui sont écrassés
dans la nuit
debout donc Jean Zigler aujourd'hui bon
on se connaît un peu. On vous a fait
revenir, on t'a fait revenir parce que
on s'intéresse beaucoup au flux
migratoires, aux déstabilisations dû à
des flux migratoires, aux guerres et
donc les flux migratoires qui sont
générés par ses propres guerres, la
famine et des choses comme ça. Ton
dernier bouquin parle de lesbos. On
avait prévu que tu viennes plus tôt mais
tu as eu quelques petits ennuis donc tu
as pas pu venir tout de suite. Là, il y
a Erdogan qui a ouvert ses frontières.
Est-ce que la flux de migrants Erdogan
détient plus de 4 millions de migrants
ou de réfugiés sur son territoire ?
Est-ce que pour vous c'est une pression
sur l'Europe parce que l'Europe ne veut
pas suivre la politique va en guerre va
en guerre de de Erdogan en Syrie et
quelle répercussion ça va avoir sur les
migrants et sur l'Europe ?
Bon, tu as tout à fait raison. Ce qui se
passe maintenant est une tragédie
effroyable pour des centaines et des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
sont en route, des réfugiés qui ont
derrière eux déjà une odée des des
expériences tout à fait tragiques. Un
réfugié syrien qui échappe au
bombardement à Ilippe. Il a subi la
torture, l'angoisse. Parfois euh les
bombardements tuent une partie de sa
famille. Ensuite, c'est l'Odyssée de la
fuite de quitter la Turquie et il bute
sur la frontière de l'Europe, ce qui est
un scandale absolu parce que l'Union
européenne a décidé de fermer sa
frontière méridionale
par euh l'intermédiaire des troupes de
choc de la police grecque qui sont à
Évros sur le en trace
sur la terre et puis sur les frontières
maritimes. dans la Mégie, dans les cinq
îles qui sont également paricadés. Or,
c'est un scandale absolu parce que
le droit d'accile si vous êtes persécuté
dans un pays dans dans votre pays
d'origine et si vous survivez et avec la
partie survivante de votre famille vous
fuyez, vous avez le droit de par le
droit international de par la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme article 14 vous avez le droit de
traverser une frontière et de demander
protection de l'autre côté de la
frontière.
Le l'État qui vous accueille examine
votre demandeile, peut la rejeter, c'est
le droit de souveraineté, peut la
rejeter ou l'accepter mais le fait de
traverser la frontière, de demander
protection, de déposer votre demande
facile est un droit de l'homme, une
conquête civilisation, un droit de
l'homme universel qui est même euh
écrit et formalisé plus précisément que
la déclaration universelle dans une
convention internationale que
pratiquement tous les États ont signé
que la convention internationale sur les
réfugiés de 51. Or, en fermant les
frontières en fermant ces frontières
d'orientale maintenant la la trace et
l'espace et bien l'Union européenne
liquide le droit d'asile. Liquide le
droit d'asile et c'est inadmissible.
Nous sommes européens, toi tu es
européen avec nos nos impôts, les
troupes de choc de la police grecque,
leur leurs chiens qui qui font la chasse
à l'homme des réfugiés sont financés en
nom. En notre nom. Alors, il faut une
insurrection des consciences. Il faut
que les Européens
je te je te je te coupe non se lève et
impose à ces têtes mul de Bruxelles, à
ces malfaiteurs l'ouverture des
frontières. l'accueil des réfugiés.
Alors,
je te coupe je te coupe dans ta lancée.
Tu as été sur l'île de Lesbos plusieurs
fois
euh euh tu as assisté. Est-ce que tu
peux nous retransmettre avec tes yeux et
tes oreilles ce que tu as pu voir, dans
quelles conditions euh euh évoluaient
les gens ? Il y a à peu près 18000
personnes, à peu près 20000 personnes
euh euh sur l'île de Lesbos dans un camp
euh qui est supposé pouvoir accueillir
environ 5000 personnes. Euh est-ce qu'on
se retrouve dans une prison une prison à
ciel ouvert ? Est-ce que on peut porter
plainte pour non respect des droits de
l'homme parce qu'on parque les gens dans
des conditions d'insalubrité gravissime
? et et fais-nous retransmets-nous ce
que tu as pu voir pour nos auditeurs,
pour nos téléspectateurs pour qu'ils
comprennent quel est le degré de
décripitude de ce camp.
Oui. Alors, mon livre s'appelle
l'esposce, la honte de l'Europe. J'ai
fait une mission pour les Nations Unie
l'année dernière dans le plus grand camp
de réfugiés sur sol européen qui est
l'île de l'Espose. L'île de l'Espos est
une île face à Turquie, 1700 km², une
très très grande île avec une
ligne côtière de 362
km. Donc, on peut pas fermer cette île.
On peut pas fermer l'accès, c'est
techniquement impossible. Et de la
Turquie voisine viennent les zodiaques,
les embarcations frères et cetera et
cetera sur cette île. Dans cette île
maintenant à l'espace à Moria dans le
camp dans une ancienne caserne, il y a à
peu près 22000 personnes. La caserne a
été construite pour 2800 personnes. Vous
imaginez la surpopulation ? Et en plus
de ça, dans les eaux olivrés autour, il
y a des camps inofficiels
et la situation
hygiénique, nutritionnelle,
sociale, psychologique est absolument
effrayante. C'est essentiellement des
réfugiés d'Afghanistan, de Syrie, du
Yémen, d'Irak, euh
Bangladesh,
du Bangladesh et cetera. Enfin de
régions euh ravagé par la guerre,
surtout la Syrie, l'Irak et le Yémen.
Derrière des barbelet en trois en triple
rangé, les barbelés de l'OTAN avec des
des rasoirs, des des des
supports de rasoir qui coupent les mains
et cetera et cetera. enferme euh 22000
personnes et il y a des milliers de
personnes dans des camps sauvages
alentours sous des plastiques et cetera
en plein hiver parce que là maintenant
où nous parlons euh l'hiver la
température dans les îes peutcendre
jusqu'à 5 euh - 5 - 5 et les gens
couchent sur des il y a pas de chauffage
évidemment pas il y a pas d'eau courante
rien du tout il y a pas d'électricité
les gens couchent en général sur des
cartons pour se protéger de de
l'humidité du sol, la nourriture. J'ai
assisté à des à des à des distributions
de nourriture
plusieurs fois. Les gens deux fois par
jour attendent 2 à 3h dans la queue
reçoivent le paquet le paquet de
plastique avec un peu de ragou, un
poulet ou un peu de poisson, du riz et
et des pompes de terre. Très très
souvent la nourriture est imangeable est
immangeable. J'ai vu les gens jeter
immédiatement la nourriture puisque la
viande puait. Il garde juste les les
pompes de terre. Elle est surtout
insuffisante parce que la corruption
ravage ces camps. le camp de Moria et
sous le sous la compétence de l'armée
grecque puisque c'est une c'est une on
viendra sur la corruption juste après
sur les
non je vais encore décrire un tout petit
peu l'absence de l'hygiène par exemple
comme il y a un il y a une cabine de
toilette métallique pour 100 personnes
en général inutilisable bouché le
l'auteur pestilentielle dans le camp est
terrible est généralisé comme il y a
très peu d'eau, très peu d'eau. Et bien
la galle par exemple c'est cette
infection de la peau et frappe les plus
faibles surtout les enfants qui font
avec les femmes 35 % de la population du
camp. Il y a une
une
des habitat soit ils sont complètement
coincés surpeuplés dans les camp dans
les dans les containers que l'eau
commissariat pour les réfugiés mais pour
deux familles un seul container 6 m² par
personne de de l'espace vital ce qui est
ce qui est terrifiante soit des grands
camps soit des grandes tentes de de
communautaire de 20 25 personnes et
surtout ces abris complètement
euh abominable dans les eau livrés dans
les eau livrés où les gens les réfugiés
qu' n'ont pas trouvé place dans le camp
ordinaire se construisent eux-mêmes avec
des branches mortes avec des plastiques
et cetera leur abri qui s'effondre tout
le temps quand il pleut quand il y a une
les rats courts morts les bébés, les les
serpents courts, les tétripus sans
tassent sans tasse euh personne les les
ramasse. Et ce qui est le pire peut-être
euh ce qui m'a le plus fait le pire,
c'est le désespoir.
Médecin sans frontière a une mission en
dehors du camp, juste à côté de l'entrée
fortifiée avec où sont les policiers
grecs surarmés et cetera et cetera.
Et c'est le seul endroit au monde où
médecin sans frontière où toute la
mission est est consacrée à la
psychiatrie enfantine parce que les
tentatives de suicide des enfants 8 9 10
ans, bah écos comme comme
mes
comme mes petits fils. Enfin, on fait
immédiatement évidemment les ils sont
tous des grands yeux noirs euh
ri malgré tout. et bien les suicides
enfants, les tentatives de suicide
enfant et surtout l'automutilation des
enfants avec des couteaux, il se
maltraite, il il se mutile le le bras ou
les jambes. Et le psychiatre, le médecin
sans frontière me dit "C'est les cris de
secours, c'est le cri de secours,
l'automusculation."
Et bien le désespoir est nourri par
l'absence d'information. Des familles
sont enfermées ter barbelé ou ou entassé
dans ces olivrés abominables depuis 3 4
ans sans aucune
information. Je te je te
Ils peuvent pas déposer leur leur
leur demande d'asile.
Leur demande d'asile. Alors voir ça en
Europe,
c'est totalement intolérable.
D'accord. C'est financé à quelle hauteur
? C'est c'est
Mais totalement
ils reçoivent combien ils reçoivent
combien d'argent pour pour organiser
cette prison à ciel ouvert ? En terme de
corruption, ça se passe comment les les
les cas de suicide et d'automutilisation
des gamins ? arrive depuis combien de
temps ? La population qui commence à
avoir ses pratiques psychiatriques, ça
fait combien de temps qu'elle est sur
l'île ? Est-ce qu'ils sont suivis ?
Est-ce que les gamins sont vaccinés ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe s'il y a une
épite coron coronavirus qui se qui se
déploie sur une île de l'esbos ? par
exemple, il y a des réfugiés iraniens
qui doivent se balader là-bas aussi
ou ou ou des choses comme ça. Est-ce
qu'on n'est pas en face d'un énorme
scandale, une bombe à retardement tant
la Turquie utilise cette bombe à
retardement pour faire des lâchés de
migrants, on appelle c'était un un
président qui disait que c'était une
attaque par les migrants. Est-ce que
c'est Erdogan attaquait l'Union
européenne avec les migrants ? Et est-ce
que l'Europe n'est pas dans un déni à
faire une politique de dissuasion en
faisant des camps insalubres pour
dissuader les gens de venir et est-ce
qu'on peut pas les traîner en justice ?
Oui, alors il y a plusieurs questions
énormément mais j'en profite parce que
comme tu parles longtemps, je veux pas
te couper.
Excuse-moi, excuse-moi, mais j'ai
tellement révolté d'après ce que j'ai vu
et que j'ai mis dans mon livre, la honte
de l'Europe, c'est une honte totale de
notre continent. Nous nous sommes
européens, c'est nos impôts qui payent
ces camps de rétention. Alors
pourquoi ces camps de rétention sur les
îles ? et bien pour décourager, pour
créer les conditions, les conditions
inhumaines abominables que je pourrais
décrire pendant pendant longtemps et qui
détruisent psychologiquement et souvent
physiquement les familles des hommes des
femmes comme vous et moi ceux qui nous
séparent des victimes.
C'est un ter de recrutement pour les
terroristes.
Bah
une population affaiblie avec des trop
psychologiques qui se sont complètement
je trouve ils sont vraiment détruits.
Quand quand quand on a vu les les
émeutes de migrants à la à la à la ou de
réfugiés à la frontière grecque, tu
les gens avaient l'air très agressif. Il
y avait beaucoup d'hommes
jeunes.
Non, mais d'abord, je veux répondre à
une question fondamentale qu'il faut
comprendre. Pourquoi l'Europe, l'Union
européenne finance tout ça ? finance les
gardes côtes grec les les gardes côtes
grecques dont les bateaux attaquent les
zodiaques dans et Frontex aussi
évidemment la la carte côtière militaire
de l'Union européenne Frontex et les
cares côt grec attaquent les zodiaques
en pleine mer avec des
immenses bâtons de de de métal parfois
tirent tout près autour des zodiaques
pour les refouler pour les refoulé dans
les autres étit grec et et ceux qui
échappent et qui arrivent sur l'espace
sont menotés dès qu'ils sont repérés
dans les dans les différentes pays dans
sur les rochers euh
mouillés évidemment transit de froid et
et et totalement angoissé et bien même
les gosses sont menaté menoté mis dans
les puces bleus et amené derrière les
barbelet à Moria. Pourquoi l'Union
européenne
fait créer des conditions aussi
abominables d'accueil et de rétention et
de prison pour les réfugiés ?
Comment il s'appelle le directeur de du
centre de l'esbour ?
Palacakis pas Yanis Palacakis. Oui, j'ai
beaucoup discuté beaucoup discuté avec.
C'est pas un méchant homme.
Et il dit quoi lui ? Bah
ceux qui coment Baka qui se disent je
n'ai pas les moyens de les nourrir
normalement, je n'ai pas les moyens de
faire des douches pour moins de 150
personnes. Je n'ai pas les moyens pour
faire de l'eau chaude en hiver. Donc les
mères peuvent pas laver leur bébé parce
qu' ils attrapent une pneumonie.
Évidemment, je n'ai pas les moyens pour
faire l'électricité. Je n'ai pas les
moyens pour acheter de la nourriture
convenable pour tout le monde parce que
euh parce que atteindre le ministre de
migration me donne pas suffisamment de
l'argent. Le et là le ministre de de de
de migration parce qu'était aussi Athène
les responsables c'était du temps de
Cypras disent "Ah, c'est l'Union
européenne qui ne paye pas assez."
Je discute à Bruxelles avec des
responsables de l'Union européenne qui
me disent on paye mais on n pas on a on
n pas les justificatifs de ces
paiements. Donc il y a une enquête
maintenant de l'office de corruption de
l'Olaf, l'Office spécialisé de
corruption pour la coupe cite la poltion
de de l'Union européenne qui a des
enquêtes fait une enquête. La la courte
compte de l'Union européenne de
Luxembourg qui sont des gens très très
précis demandent par exemple depuis 3
ans les contrats qui lient les généraux
au traiteurs grecs qui fournissent la
nourriture puisqueévidemment les
généraux se sucrent et et les traiteurs
donnent une nourriture insuffisante.
Mais je voudrais répondre à ces
questions fondamentales. Pourquoi
l'Union européenne qui sont quand même
des gens civilisés, l'Union européenne
crée intentionnellement
des conditions abominables d'accueil, de
détention de ses réfugiés. C'est l'Union
européenne
a un seul but, c'est de réduire
siamment c'est siamment organisé.
Siamment siamment veut réduire l'arrivée
l'arrivée le nombre d'arrivées des
réfugiés. C'est pas de l'incompétence.
Non, le non. Le réfugié à Bruxelles est
vu comme un danger pour l'Europe.
D'abord le commissaire le commissaire
margitis qui s'occupe qui a le cas
migration
de migration s'appelle
s'appelle
euh s'appelle doit protéger un
commandant pour protéger le mode de vie
le mode de vie européen. Donc il faut
réduire le nombre des réfugiés qui
arrivent et donc il crée des conditions
abominables dans ces camp dans ces camp
dans les cinq îs dans dans abominable
que j'ai décrit tout à l'heure
espérant que la nouvelle circule au
Yémen, au en Irak, en Syrie et que
d'autres milliers dizaines de milliers
de réfugiés renoncent à venir app à
prendre l'Afrique. Or c'est une idioc
totale et ça fonctionne pas. Ça se
montre là, ils sont en route, il vient
ils sont sur la frontière sud de
l'Europe maintenant des milliers des
dizaines des dizaines de rédip
maintenant où nous discutons cet
instant-là euh nous discut le 3 mars, il
y a des bombardements de terreur sur
Dip, sur ces provinces du nord-ouest
nord-ouest de la Syrie. Le meurtrier de
masse qui est Vadimir Poutine et qui est
Alassad bombarde systématiquement
les quartier d'habitation, les hôpitaux,
les marchés, les écoles. Bah si vous
vivez dans une telle terreur, si vous
êtes confronté à une stratégie
meurtrière de terre brûlée, vous partez.
Vous partez, si vous avez encore un
enfant vivant, quels que soient les
nouvelles qui vous proviennent de
l'espos. Donc l'Union européenne se
trompe deux fois d'une part en en
liquidant le droit d'acile, en refusant
de permettre et d'examiner la demande de
droit d'accile. Il viole les fondements
moraux de sa propre construction puisque
les accords de Rome de 57 qui ont créer
la communauté européenne afin qui sont à
l'origine lointaine de l'Union
européenne aujourd'hui
sont ont créé un état de droit
continental sont basés sur le respect
des droits humains. Donc cette base
morale de l'Union européenne est
liquidée dans la mergée aujourd'hui et
en même temps cette stratégie de la
terreur appliquée par l'Union européenne
siamant est inefficace politiquement
puisque les réfugiés
faudra il faudra arrêter de faire la
guerre faudra arrêter de déstabiliser
d'autres d'autres
Non non il faut il faut pas faire la
gymnastique dans le ciel bleu il y a des
choses très précises qu'il faut faire
l'Union européenne a en en cesse créer,
négocier
diplomatiquement, multilatéralement
négocier la
un plan de relocalisation
de relocalisation, c'est-à-dire chaque
état membre à l'époque il était 28,
aujourd'hui ils sont 27, chaque État
membre doit recevoir tant de réfugiés,
accueillir tant de
Je t'ouvre une parenthèse tout de suite.
Question d'internet : "Chiffrez-vous une
limite de capacité d'accueil de l'Europe
?" Non mais attends, je vais tab je tab
terminer puis je réponds à cette
question qui est très juste. Euh un plan
de relocalisation selon le problème
produit intérieur brut et la capacité
démographique
et les huit états
de l'Europe exsoviétique et de l'Europe
de l'Est refuse net tous d'accueillir le
moindre réfugié. Je cite dans mon livre
et je vais quand même le montrer parce
que euh
les citations sont là-dedans. Je cite
ici je cite ici le Premier ministre
polonais qui dit qui dit publiquement,
je le cite, qui dit publiquement nous
n'accueillons pas de réfugiés en Pologne
parce que nous devons sauvegarder la
pureté ethnique, la pureté et de la
Pologne. C'est un vocabulaire nazi. Or
que fait que font les têtes mules de
Bruxelles, les malfaiteurs de Bruxelles
au lieu d'affronter ce racisme,
d'affronter les racistes urbanes, les
Bulgares, les Roumains et cetera, les
Slovaques et cetera, les Slovaes, au
lieu de les affronter et de leur couper
les subventions européennes parce qu'ils
vivent certains jusqu'à 80 %, c'est des
États entiers jusqu'à 80 % des des
subventions notamment au au titre de la
compensation régionale. c'est une des
une des caisses principales des 12
caisses de l'Union européenne et de
sanctionner
sanctionner le refus des réfugiés, de
sanctionner les les de sanctionner les
racistes Varsovi de de
de
d'Hongrie par exemple en Hongrie par
exemple Orbandi quiconque traverse la
frontière hongroise et bien tris 3 ans
de prison. Or, pour un réfugié, il n'y a
pas de traversée illégale d'une
frontière puisque le droit international
lui donne le droit de chercher refuge et
protection. Ailleurs,
je reviens, je reviens à la question. a
des chiens dressés à la chasse aux
enfants au réfugiés sur la frontière
hongroise. Et ces chiens, leur dressage
la chasse à l'homme est payé par vos
impôts. To c'est un impôt et et mes
impôts c'est totalement intolérable.
Alors, je vais terminer mon
je terminer l'argumentation parce qu'il
faut savoir ce qu'il y a derrière ces
stratégie détestable de terreur de
l'Union européenne. Évidemment, l'Union
européenne et c'est normal, on peut pas
lui reprocher, est très très préoccupé
par la montée des mouvements xénophobes
en Europe. l'Alliance for Deutschland en
Allemagne qui a plus de de députés au
bondstag que le parti social-démocrate.
Vous imaginez maintenant le monté en
puissance de madame Le Pen en France de
Salvini et de la LGA en Italie et cetera
et cetera et les commissaires de l'Union
européenne pensent qu'en réduissant les
réfugiés, ils peuvent apaiser les
racistes en Europe. Or, c'est une erreur
totale. J'ai j'ai parlé de Munique,
c'est un Munique, j'ai parlé de ça dans
mon livre. C'est Munich comme quand les
occidentaux européens occidentaux
rencontré les Hitler à Munique en 38, on
dit oui, vous pouvez vous pouvez annexer
les communautés allemandes en en
Tchikoslovaquie, les sud-est et cetera
et cetera espérant
d'apaiser la folie guerrière de Hitler
et apaiser la la progresse, la la
xénophobie, le racisme de d'apaiser le
racisme en
avec eux, c'est une erreur fondamentale.
Un antisémite, un antiamique, un raciste
est un ennemi de l'humanité. Pointe à la
ligne. Un ennemi de l'humanité. On peut
pas lui faire des concessions. On peut
pas croire que si on lui donne le petit
doigt et bien il vous prend le bras. Si
on vous donne le bras, il vous prend le
corps entier. un raciste et l'Union
européenne a raison d'être préoccupé par
par ce qui se passe au niveau les
mouvements sociaux en Europe dans des
vieilles sociétés comme la France, comme
l'Allemagne, comme l'Espagne, comme
l'Italie où tout à coup cette folie
xénophobe se transforme en victoire
électorale qui se succède. L'Union
européenne a raison d'être préoccupé
mais sa réaction est totalement erronée.
historiquement prouver que c'est erroné
avec un raciste. On peut pas discuter,
négocier, trouver un arrangement,
l'apaiser par des concessions. Un
raciste, il faut le combattre par tous
les moyens démocratiques qu'on a avec la
loi, avec la police, tous, hein. Mais
jamais faire le moindre pas en sa
direction. Donc croire qu'en réduisant
par des moyens abominables
violant la loi internationale, les camps
de concentration en M régé les les
rangées de policiers grecs surarmés.
Camp de concentration, c'est lourd comme
signification,
c'est les
camp de concentration,
ça rappelle des camps de concentration
ce que j'ai vu et le terme est aussi
utilisé par le médecin sans frontière.
Et bien c'est une erreur totale de
l'Union européenne de croire qu'avec des
moyens terroristes en fermant des
frontières et je reviens à la question
que tout à l'heure la personne m'a posé.
Chiffrez-vous une limite de capacité
d'accueil de l'Europe ?
Non.
La question internet.
Bah non.
Il n'y a pas de
le droit à l'asile de chercher
protection dans un autre pays, de
déposer une demande d'assile quand vous
êtes martyrisé, quand torturé, bombardé
dans votre pays d'origine. Ce droit-là
est un droit de l'homme universel, une
conquête civilisation
et tous les droits de l'homme, les 51
droits de l'homme de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme que
tous les 193 États membres de l'Union
européenne et de de des Nations Unies
ont signé,
ils ont adérés à la déclaration
universelle de 1948 de de l'ONU.
Tous les droits de l'homme sont
universels,
indépendants et indivisibles.
Alors, on peut pas dire on respecte le
droit d'asile jusqu'à 1 million de
personnes. Après, on ferme les
frontières, on refuse de respecter le
droit. C'est comme le droit de ne pas
être torturé. Il y a un article dans la
déclaration un des droits de l'homme qui
garantit l'intégrité physique de tout
être humain. Donc l'interdiction de la
torture. Et bien on peut pas dire ouais
on l'intégrité physique de tant de gens
nous le garantissons. Le reste on peut
les torturer librement. C'est une
absurdité. fermer les frontières. Ce qui
se passe maintenant, nous parlons dans
une actualité, un moment où une
actualité, tu l'as dit tout à l'heure,
totalement tragique se se concrétise sur
le fleuve en en trace au nord de la
Grèce et sur les îles de la mer.
fermeture des frontières Europe par
policiers surarmés par bateau de guerre
de Frontex interposé. Euh
cette FP de frontière est totalement
criminel, est une violation totale. Je
je te repose la la question internet.
Quand quand à combien est-ce que il y a
on a écouté tous les points de vue sur
ce sujet-là depuis un certain nombre de
mois, un certain nombre d'années,
il y en a qui disent voilà au bout d'un
moment le nombre de migrants ou de
réfugiés qui va venir en Europe va
déstabiliser
les routes migratoires et attends
attends laisse-moi terminer. et va
déstabiliser les pays en question, les
pays d'arrivé.
Ça c'est dur.
Donc je te pose la question.
Fantasma.
L'Union européenne a 551
millions de personnes qui l'habitent.
551 millions de personnes qui habitent
les 27 pays. En plus,
c'est la plus grande puissance
économique du monde. Un produit
intérieur brut de plus de 10000
milliards de d'euros. Tu veux pas me
dire ? et et le haut commissariat pour
les réfugiés des Nations- Unies évalue à
5 millions de personnes maximum qui
Méditerranéen et central comprise Libye
comprise et Turquie comprise à 5
millions de personnes qui vont se mettre
en route qui cherchent refuge en Europe.
Aucun réfugié veut partir de chez lui.
Être réfugié est une douleur est est
extrêmement
traumatisant et dangereux qu'un réfugié
veut partir. Et bien
5 millions selon nos commissariats pour
des réfugiés qui demandent l'entrée en
Europe, tu veux pas me dire que 5
millions de personnes peuvent pas être
absorbé, intégré si la reloc
relocalisation
est est bien faite dans un bassin
démographique de plus de 550
millions ferm les frontiers. Je je j'ai
un je suis un peu j'insiste un peu sur
le point parce que je suisse
personne n'est parfait hein.
Personne n'est parfait. Mais je non
j'aime le peuple suisse mais pas
l'oligarchie bancaire. Pas l'oligarchie
bancaire qui est qu'il faut combattre
l'argent du sang qui s'accumule du monde
entier qui p qui p le tiers monde
entier. Je je prends
un verre d'au là si tu veux.
Tu as un verre d'eau juste à ta droite
si tu as besoin.
Ah, tu penses que je te mémoire le livre
? Non,
le livre on va le voir après. Excellent.
Tu as un verre d'ou juste à droite.
Je vais prendre les pour
Donc je je me permets de faire une
excursion dans la dans la
l'histoire suisse, un événement qui me
traumatise bien que j'étais petit enfant
à l'époque en avril 1943
la Suisse était neutre.
La guerre ravage l'Europe. Les monstres
nazis étaient au pouvoir partout. La
France était par terre. En Afrique 43,
le conseil fédéral et le commandement de
l'armée qui occupait les frontières,
conseil fédéral, c'est le gouvernement,
ont décidé de refuser toute entrée à
tout réfugié.
avril 43, c'est quand les monstres naz
ont commencé à déporter les juifs dans
l'Europe occidentale, la Hollande, en
France et cetera et cetera. La Suisse a
fermé les frontières avec
une un argument qui est devenu célèbre
et qui
ta spot is f, c'est-à-dire la barque est
pleine. La barque est pleine. Nous
n'avons nous la barque est pleine. Nous
sommes assez nombreux en Suisse et
cetera. On peut pas accepter les à la
frontière jeunoise, à la frontière
vaudoise, à la frontière tessinoise côté
italien euh à la frontière suisse
allémanque balic et cetera. Les soldats
suisses ont repoussé des enfants juifs
entre les mains des SS qui étaient de
l'autre côté des barbelés.
Ferme-tu tes frontières ? Et bien la
même chose se passe maintenant de
nouveau par la volonté de l'Union
européenne en trace et dans la mer et
j'ai alors au moment de de
43 avril 43 où des juifs par milliers
miraculeusement sont arrivés jusqu'au
barblé jusque surmonté du du drapeau à
la Croix Blanche Suisse et et ont été
repoussés par les bayon honnête des
soldats suisses des soldats suisses
entre les mains encore une fois des
assassins nazis et ils sont morts la
plupart évidemment
c'est un crime
qu'aucune mémoire ne va jamais effacer.
Il y a aucune justification quelconque.
La barque est pleine.
Quand vous remettez au bourreau alors là
c'est on remet pas un bourreau les
réfugiés qui sont repoussés à la
frontière d'Evros par exemple notre
trace on les renvoie
à
dans les champs trempés par la pluie les
enfants. Il y a des il y a 33 enfants
selon les les Nations- Unies dans ces sa
son trampon qui sont morts de froid qui
sont morts de froid. En février en
février ê mort de froid, on les repousse
vers la destruction physique, le
désespoir et cetera. Donc je me permets
de revenir à ce que la personne tout à
l'heure a dit. Combien de gens peut
l'Europe accepter ?
Cette question n'a pas le lieu d'être.
Quand un réfugié elle a le droit de
demander assile, de chercher protection,
de traverser une frontière de par la loi
internationale, et bien il faut
l'accueillir quel que soit leur nombre.
Quel que soit leur nombre, on peut pas
dire on respecte les droits de l'homme
jusque à un chiffre plafonné X et puis
ce qui est au-delà et bien c'est des
animaux qu'on peut abattre, qu'on peut
repousser, qu'on peut affamer et cetera.
Non, c'est toujours des hommes, tous des
femmes, des enfants qui ont les mêmes
droits inanaliables
et les têtes béton de Mul, les
malfaiteurs de Bruxelles en fermant la
frontière, en armant la police grecque,
en payant les chiens qui font la chasse
à l'homme sur la frontière de trace ou
en créant des conditions de vie
totalement effroyables
à l'espace. et bien
violent le droit et doivent être
combattu mais doivent être combattu. OK.
On fait on on fait comment pour les
combattre ? On va les voir, on refuse de
payer leurs impôts
parce que c'est c'est compliqué. Il y a
il y a il y a il y a 5 millions il y a 5
millions de de réfugiés en attente.
Ça fait un demi-Portugal.
C'est c'est jouable
un demi- Portugal. Mais là, on nous dit
qu'il y a environ 60 millions de
personnes qui veulent migrer vers
l'Europe.
Non,
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai ?
Mais pas du tout.
Le chiffre de 60 millions
fait la V du diable, c'est fait exprès.
Non, mais c'est c'est un diable mal
informé. Alors le
je m'excuse, je suis un peu mal poli.
C'est imprudent avec un grand chef
malpi. Non, il y a 60 millions de
personnes qui sont en route dans le
monde,
au Texas et cetera, ça dans le monde,
en Afrique, la plupart du temps,
plupart à l'intérieur des continents.
et les réfugiés de les réfugiés de la
violence de la violence pas des gens qui
se mettent en route parce qu'il a rien à
manger des réfugiés de la violence qui
tombent sous la convention de 51 sont au
maximum 25 millions. Je gif des Nations-
Unies que je suis des Nations- Unies,
j'ai une relative,
je suis très critique face aux Nations
Unies, mais les bureaucrate des Nations
Unies, ça fait des statistiques, ça ça
ils savent le faire. Il y a 25 millions
de réfugiés de la violence qui tombent
sur sur le sur la convention sur les
réfugiés de 51 article article 3.
De ces 25 millions, la grande majorité
est déplacée à l'intérieur du Yémen, du
Sud Soudan, de la Syrie, de l'Irak, de
l'Afghanistan sont dép sont déplacés
intérieur des réfugiés à l'intérieur des
pays et 5 millions sont sur la frontière
sud de l'Europe estimation des Nations
Unies.
4 millions en Turquie,
4 millions en Turquie, ensuite la Libye
et cetera le T3 de de Gibraltar et
cetera.
Alors quand votre interlocuteur, ton
interlocuteur demande combien peut
l'Europe peut peut accueillir, bah avec
550 millions de populations
continentales
intégrer 5 millions, même si les 5
millions venaient tous en même temps, et
bien on peut le faire. Ce qu'il faut, et
je le redis, c'est appliquer le plan de
relocalisation négocié par l'Union
européenne, c'est-à-dire de forcer les
pays de l'Est, xénophobe, protascistes,
racistes, souvent comme ce premier
ministre polonais que je cite dans mon
livre, la honte de l'Europe. Et bien
leur couper les vivres pour les forcer
àir réfugiés. Si les réfugiés étit
normalement distribué, l'intégration
poserait aucun aucun problème. Ferme les
frontières est un crime.
Les pays du golf, ils ont fermé leur
frontières. Pourquoi il y a pas descend
de
Oui, mais parlons parlons de l'Europe.
C'est nous c'est nous. Vous comprenez ?
pays de golf bien sûr l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est une horreur enfin c'est une
dictature moyenneuse
mais parlons de l'Europe notre
responsabilité vous voulez échapper vous
je sens là intellectuel français qui
veut échapper à sa à sa responsabilité
non
tous les pays européens les grands pays
qui sont décisifs l'Italie la France
l'Allemagne sont des démocraties
en démocratie il n'y a pas d'impuissance
Nous avons toutes touses les armes
constitutionnelles à main. Il suffit de
se baisser, les ramasser, les libertés
publiques citoyennes,
les droits de l'homme.
Nous pouvons forcer par les moyens
légaux que nous avons nos gouvernements
d'intervenir à Bruxelles pour changer
radicalement [grognement]
cette politique de la terreur, du
refoulement de la dissuasion appliquée
au réfugiés maintenant la transformer en
une politique d'accueil, d'hospitalité,
d'intégration
et surtout de respect
du droit d'assons
l'obtenir. Il y a pas il y a il y a pas
d'impuissance. Moi je fais beaucoup pour
ce livre là, je fais beaucoup de je fais
beaucoup de conférences. Bah
heureusement que je peux m'exprimer c
chaque fois quelqu'un à la fin de la
conférence euh parce qu'il y a des
traduction de livres à Matride et cetera
et cetera, à Matride à Milan et cetera
ou en France à Bordeaux
lève la main dit "Vous avez raison ce
que vous dites dans votre livre c'est
juste c'est abominable cette politique
de terreur de l'Union européenne de
refourement en haute mè par la violence
des zodiaques
de réfugiés transit désespéré angoissé.
Vous avez raison. Mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je fasse ? Qu'est-ce que
rien à faire ? On peut rien faire. C'est
Bruxelles qui décide, c'est les premier
ministres, c'est le c'est le conseil des
ministres qui est l'organe suprême
au-dessus même de de la commission qui
est l'exécutif de l'Union européenne.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse ?
Et bien, c'est de l'aliénation.
C'est une des plus grandes victoires le
triomphe final du système capitaliste.
Viduader
les citoyens des pays démocratiques
qu'ils sont finalement impuissants.
Est-ce que tuas Est-ce que tu as été
cette aliénation doit être combattue ?
C'est tout.
Est-ce que tu as Oui. Non mais c'est
c'est plus facile dire qu'à faire.
Oui, mais c'est c'est pas le fait de la
gymnastique,
c'est une tâche précise, politique,
immédiate, concrète.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. Non mais les gens
je me fais l'avoquer du diable encore.
Mais tu me crois pas.
C'est non mais moi j'étudie les flux
migratoires sur Mayotte depuis 12 ans.
D'accord. Donc des gens qui avaient qu'
qui avaient la la lèpre
dans la jungle Maorè, j'en ai vu les
bidonville de Mayotte, je les ai vu de
très très près. T'inquiète pas, c'est un
sujet qui me prend vraiment à cœur mais
je me dois de me faire l'avocat du
diable et de poser toutes les questions
et qu'on en parle sans filtre.
Très
du côté turc, comment ça se passe ?
Est-ce que tu as été visité là-bas ?
Est-ce que tu as eu des retours ? Est-ce
que géopolitiquement parlant, est-ce que
Erdogan a fait cette poche de migrants
pour pouvoir faire pression sur
l'Europe, plutôt pression sur les
dirigeants européens et les partis
politiques européens ? Est-ce que tu as
vu des choses comme ça ? Est-ce que tu
as été baladé en Turquie du côté turc ?
Bon,
c'est pas un état de droit. Je pense que
Erdogan est un dictateur, un malfaiteur
qui massacre les curdes et cetera et qui
a fait un détour. Je prends un exemple
qui m'a beaucoup frappé.
L'Union européenne lui l'Union
européenne lui a payé 3 milliards de
dollars pour s'occuper des millions de
Turcs.
De quand à quand ? De quand à quand ?
De 16 à 19. Donc tu tu tu dis de l'entre
Merkel et Ordogan, on peut entrer
1 milliard par an.
Mil, il a utilisé essensé. Bon, les les
Syriens, les iakiens, les afghans, les
Yéénites qui sont en Turquie
physiquement
n'ont pas l'asile. Ils vivent sous ce
système de protection provisoire. Une
partie de l'argent que l'Union
européenne a a payé est allée à la
construction de mur de 728
km le long de la frontière syrienne
et et turque. Et ce mur est effrayant et
fait est muni de mitrailleuses
autodéclenchant, c'est-à-dire le réfugié
qui avance à à 300 m
sur le mur
est arrêté par une loi, par un
avertissement en trois langues qui dit
retourner.
S'il ne retourne pas, s'il continue à
avancer, les mitrailleuses
autodéclenchantes,
le tir est commence à tirer le tu qui
sont montés sur ce mur.
Ça ça a été financé par notre argent.
Et ça a été financé par tes impôts, par
ton argent.
Bon, ça c'est Erdogan. etan renvoie en
Syrie des centaines et des milliers de
réfugiés. De toute façon aussi, c'est un
état de non droit de non droit.
Alors
maintenant,
il est empétré évidemment à ild les
troupes turques luttent contre les
troupes de Bachar Al-Assad et pour
forcer l'Union européenne et les
Européens et l'Occident en général de
l'appuyer, de prendre son parti, il a
ouvert les frontières qui étaient
fermées jusqu'à maintenant, ouvert les
frontières
encourageant les mettant dans le début,
c'est les amenant à la frontière, la
migration, le déplacement de centaines
de milliers de réfugiés direction
Europe.
Bon, c'est une stratégie qui est un
cynisme total, mais moi comme européen,
comme enfin comme comme intellectuel au
combat, comme citoyen libre qui peut
s'exprimer,
je dis la réaction de l'Union européenne
qui arme la police grecque
et qui demande la fermeture et qui
effectivement organisé la fermeture de
la frontière méritonale
dans la mergé et et dans les bros la
rivière en en trace qui fait la
frontière fermeture des frontière est
aussi détestable
que du temps d'avril 43
où l'armée suisse et le gouverneur
suisse ont fermé hermétiquement
la frontière de la confédération
elviétique
pour empêcher des réfugiés des
persécutés des juifs persécutés par les
monstres nazis de trouver refuge sur
territoire elevétique c'est la même
situation c'est aussi inadmissible
détestable et il faut se lever
l'insurrection des consiste qui dit
qu'il faut se lever c'est magnifique
comment [rires]
un homme vivant je sais je est-ce qu'il
y a
je comprends que tu comprends pas ça
si je comprends mais je me fais l'avocat
du diable
fermer les frontiers
laisse-moi laisse-moi terminer
les religions
oui
autour des des politiques de migration,
des politiques de de réfugiés, qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ? Est-ce que le pape s'est
déplacé à l'esbos ? Est-ce que le pape a
débloqué des des crédits de l'église
pour pouvoir aider les les réfugiés ?
Est-ce que les musulmans ont fait
pareil, les bouddhistes ? Est-ce que il
y a il y a une aide internationale
autour de ça ? Bon, d'abord euh la
religion euh je réponds avec Victor Hugo
comme Victor Hugo. Je déteste toutes les
églises, j'aime les hommes, je crois en
Dieu. Bah c'est mon cas, c'est mon cas.
Terminé.
Le pape jésu François plutôt un typien
enfin je le connais pas, je l'ai jamais
rencontré mais il est allé à l'empous
pour témoigner
ses hotspot en sud de l'Italie pour
témoigner sa solidarité personnelle avec
les persécutés survivants qui arrivent
par le bateau. Il est allé à l'espos
et c'est lui qui a utilisé ça rappelle
la phrase ça rappelle les camps de
concentration
2017 un pape. Je pense que le
Saint-Esprit était un peu dans le coup
mais enfin c'est incroyable. Vous
imaginez un pape qui dit ça alors qui
vit dans ce Vatican
qui est une cour médiévale de nuque
terrible avec ses ses chassubles rouges,
ces ces chaussettes violentes violettes
et cetera ce Vatican qui est terrible
comme institution là en plein milieu, il
a ce pape
extraordinaire extraordinaire
alors je pense qu'il fait ce qu'il peut
pour réveiller les gens
Il
il prend il prend des gens au Vatican,
il héberge des migrants. Est-ce que le
le public
il est ramené avec de Grèce, il est
ramené revenu avec
une famille. Ouais, avec une famille.
Évidemment le
si tu m'intro si tu me pousses dans mes
tenir, je trouve qu'il y a tellement de
Raphaël, de Michelange, de trésors
incroyables au Vatican entassé. Il y a
une banque plein d'or et cetera et
cetera. s'il avait le pouvoir et je
crois pas qu'il a le pouvoir hein parce
que enfin bref s avait le pouvoir et
s'il décidait de vendre les richesse du
Vatican et de donner l'argent pour
l'accueil des réfugiés par exemple ou la
lutte contre la fin qui est le qui est
le scandale
premier de notre temps. Tous les
5 secondes d'un enfant, je le répète,
tous les 5 secondes d'un enfant en
dessous de 10 ans sur cette planète qui
débord richesse meur de faim. Et puisque
je j'ai des rapporteurs spécials, je
l'ai déjà dit, pour le droit à
l'alimentation pendant 8 ans de l'Union
de de de de l'ONU, le même rapport
World Food Report euh rapport sur
l'insécurité alimentaire dans le monde
de la FAO qui sort tous les printemps de
prochainement sorti dans ce mois et qui
donne le chiffre le chiffre des
victimes. le même rapport de la FAO de
l'Organisation des Nations Unies pour
l'agriculture et la nourriture qui donne
le chiffre des victimes que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure dit que l'agriculture
mondiale
dans l'étape actuelle de ces forces de
production pour les nourrir normalement
2200 calories calories individuelles par
jour pourrait nourrir normalement 12
milliards d'êtres humains. Nous sommes
7,3 pour l'instant. Autrement dit, s'il
avait une distribution normative juste
équitable de la nourriture sur ces
planète, si c'était pas dépendant du
pouvoir d'achat accès à la nourriture,
et bien presque le double de l'humanité
pourrait être nourriment
demain matin. matin. Or le massacre
quotidien de la fin des enfants des plus
faibles et cetera par millions continué
après année. Je te donne un dernier chi
je donne un dernier chiffre.
Tous les ans à peu près
70 millions de personnes
quittent la planète. Donc tout toutes
les causes de mort
additionné l'année dernière.
72 millions de personnes sont mortes,
ont quitté ont quitté cette planète.
14 %
par la fin ou de ces suites immédiates,
les quat corps, noma et cetera et
autrement dit sur une planète qui
pororte richesse, la fin aujourd'hui
encore est de loin la première cause de
mort
sur cette planète.
Quelque chose ne joue pas dans cet ordre
de capitaliste du monde. Quelque chose
ne joue pas.
Quelque chose joue très bien.
Quelque chose joue très bien pour
l'oligarchie qui contrôle les richesses
de cette planète. Bien sûr,
tu fais peur à la classe qui travaille
en disant si tu travailles pas, si tu
m'obis pas, tu vas finir comme eux. Bon,
OK, on a compris. Je prends un seul
exemple. l'année dernière selon la
Banque mondiale les 500 plus grandes
sociétés transcontinentales privées tout
secteur confondu industrie, banque
service et confondu. Les 500 plus
grandes sociétés de transcontinental
privé ont contrôlé 52,8
% du produit mondial brut, c'est-à-dire
de toutes les richesses produites en une
année sur la planète pour la lite.
Ces sociétés transc ces oligarchies du
capital financier globalisé très étroit
ont un pouvoir comme jamais un roi,
jamais un pape, jamais un empereur n'a
eu sur cette planète. Elles s'échappent
à tout contrôle étatique par sont plus
puissants que la plus grand
des État. Je poulais j'ai écrit un livre
là-dessus, je m'excuse, je me cite
toujours moi-même, mais c'est la vanité
des écrivains. Le capitalisme expliqué à
ma petite fille dans l'espoir
qu'elle enverra la fin qu' enverra la
fin.
Et bien aucun contrôle syndical, social,
étatique ou intérêt ne limite l'action
de cette oligarchie.
Elle est plus puissante que n'importe
quel autre pouvoir dans l'histoire des
hommes. Elle sait faire beaucoup de
choses. Les multinationales
contrôlent le processus scientifique,
les découverts, technologiques et elle
sait faire beaucoup de choses mais a un
seul l'oligarchie a un seul principe,
c'est la maximalisation du profit dans
le temps le plus court et pratiquement
n'importe quel prix humain. et bien il
gouvernent la planète, on peut les
abattre la sélection des conscience.
Donc je je je te renvoie au sujet de
l'émission avec une question internet
l'ON qui n'est pas une question si qui
est une question de quoi
la question la question internet c'est
l'ONU annonce 250 millions de réfugiés
climatiques en 2050
comment peut-on espérer que cela ne se
finisse pas en boucherie
bah c'est des questions justes, je veux
dire c'est réaliste puisque c'est vrai
l'ONU pense que qu'il y aura des
millions et des millions et des millions
de réfugiés climatiques, c'estd qui
quittent leur terre complètement
desséchée où les sources d'au sont tari
et cetera et cetera. l'ONU envissage
cette perspective. Bah c'est tout la
lutte
pour contre le réchauffement climatique
pour sauver le climat. Le
il y a 3 ans 4 ans maintenant la 2015 la
COP Paris.
Ah non mais enfin c'était quand même un
moment important où les principaux états
du monde ont fait des promesses précises
et ont dit il faut prendre des mesures
pour éviter qu'à la fin du siècle le
réchauffement climatique dépasse les 2
degrés
supplémentaires. C'est de D parce que si
c'est si c'était le cas, si le
réchauffement climatique n'est pas
maîtrisé et le réchauffement serait de 4
5 ou 6 degrés supplémentaires, et bien
il aura
les mers montré, il aurait plus de ville
portuaire, nique ni Bordeaux, ni
Hambourg ni Marseille. Les villes
portuaires disparaîtraient dans des
océans qui augmentent. Il aura en effet,
comme dit tout à l'heure la personne qui
a posé la question,
un desséchement des terres massif et
donc une migration
des réfugiés des réfugiés de la fin de
la fin qui se déverserait probablement
en Europe, venant d'Afrique et cetera et
cetera.
Il aurait une catastrophe pour la
biodiversité,
il aura une catastrophe pour la fin dans
le monde effrayante. Donc il faut
lutter, c'est une urgence absolue
absolue pour réduire le réchauffement
climatique et on est très mal pass
depuis 2015 le coronavirus, ça va nous
aider un peu,
non ? depuis 2015.
Ouais.
Euh je je prends l'exemple pas je prends
un seul exemple qui montre comment les
oligarchies empêche euh cette lutte. Par
exemple,
il y a un annexe numéro 5 aux accords de
Paris qui parle de la de l'industrie
pétrolière parce que le CO2, enfin le le
euh le fossile, la l'énergie fossile
produit le plus de CO2. Donc il faut
réduire l'énergie fossile très
rapidement pour que le CO2 envoyé dans
l'atmosphère soit également réduit. et
on demande les les les États ont pris
l'engagement
de d'obtenir
des grands trustes pétroliers une
réduction
de leur production très rapide jusqu'en
2013 30 réduction de leur production et
un transfert d'une partie c'est 40 % de
leur profit dans la recherche des
énergies renouvelables
or 4 ans après où on attend
l'augmentation de la production
pétrolière a augmenté de 28 % parmi les
5 an en moyenne en 28 % si on prend le
total des augmentations de production
pour les cinq principals trusts
d'une part a augmenté et ce que les
pétroliers ont transféré investi dans la
recherche de d'énergie renouvelable
solaire énergie et cetera, hydraulique
et cetera et cetera est exactement 17 %
au lieu de 40. Donc ça montre bien que
l'oligarchie
est au pouvoir, est aux commandes
et met échec une par exemple des
revendications centrales intelligentes
centrales nécessaires de la copée de
Paris. Donc le combat, l'ennemi est
clair, c'est l'oligarchie. Le combat qui
nous incombe est également
clair.
Question internet.
Indiscutable.
Question internet. Que fait le haut
commissariat au réfugiés à l'ONU ?
Pourquoi ne disperse-t-il pas les
réfugiés sur les sur tous les États
membres au lieu de permettre à l'Union
européenne de les parquer ?
Combien il g combien il gagne combien il
gagne le le haut commissaire au réfugiés
?
Le
combien il gagne le haut commissaire au
réfugiés de l'ONU ?
C'est un D1, ça doit être dans les
dollars par mois, je pense. D'abord, il
est bien grandi.
Philippo grandi, c'était toute sa vie
était bien. dire était un étudiant très
catholique de l'université de Milan et
depuis la fin des études, il est engagé
soit dans des ONG euh
plutôt catholique, soit dans des dans
l'aide au réfugiés depuis longtemps au
commissariat et grandi comme personne,
comme motivation, comme intelligence
diplomatique qui négocie et cetera est
un typien et le haut commissariat est
une institution assez formidable. Il y a
il a une un temps de réactivité de 48 he
c'est a des dépôts partout dans les dans
les différents continents. S'il a un
afflux massif des réfugiés comme du
Rwanda au Congo en 94 par exemple, je
prends cet exemple là oùù plus de 2
millions de personnes presque 2 millions
de personnes sont arrivées au Congo dans
les provinces orientales du Congo. En 48
heh, les premières latrines sont
creusées, les premiers dispensaires sont
érigés, les tentes d'accueil sont
construites et cetera et cetera. Il y a
une efficacité formidable dans le haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés. Alors la
question est très juste. Pourquoi le
haut commissaire laisse faire l'horreur,
l'enfer de Moria que j'ai que j'ai
décrite dans mon livre ?
Bah la réponse est relativement simple.
Euh c'est le principe de subsidiarité.
La stratégie et c'est le principe
partout appliqué. Ce que un état membre
de l'ONU peut faire, le le commissaire
ne le fait pas. Il a un budget qui a
baissé.
Il y a une multitude d'interventions
nécessaires au sud-soudan au enfin
partout dans le monde où le le
commissaire est est sollicité. Là,
l'Union européenne a dit ce qui concerne
en ce qui concerne la Grèce, nous
payons, nous dirigeons, nous fixons la
stratégie, nous la mettons en œuvre.
pointe à pointe à et grandi a dit de
subsidarité on le fait il a des il y a
il y a un bureau du haut commissaire il
y a un bureau du haut commissaire à il y
a un bureau du haut commissaire à
Mitilini que je visité
une jeune femme très
très bien qui représente le haut
commissaire le haut commissaire si on
lui demande fourn des containers C'est
ces cabanons métalliques ou deux
familles maintenant puisqu'on a fermé au
milieu par une par un droit parce qu'il
y a tellement tellement de monde et il y
a deux chalis euh des choses comme ça il
fait mais la responsabilité
par exemple je me suis excusez-moi de
thème avec cette jeune femme je veux pas
dire son nom il est dans mon livre je je
l'ai dit dans mon livre Après euh j'ai
eu une discussion assez violente en dans
le bureau du haut commissariat à
Mitilini, donc dans la capitale de de
l'espos
sur le problème de l'alimentation
parce que l'alimentation, je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure des réfugiés est tout à
fait insuffisante et souvent immangable.
Tout le monde, j'ai eu assez de
processus de le dos donc je suis
prudente en ce que je dis. Tout le monde
dit c'est le département, c'est le
département de la défense, c'est les
généraux grecs qui sont corrompus, qui
font des accords avec tr traiteurs des
traiteurs de du continent du continent
d'Athè et cetera qui par bateau livre et
mythilini deux fois par par jour la
nourriture mais souvent de la nourriture
à varié la différence est empochée par
les généraux c'est ce que ce qui se dit
généralement dans les ONG à l'espace
et j'ai dit ça à la déléguée du haut
commissariat dans son bureau à Mitini
jeune femme bon qui maîtrisait
parfaitement le vocabulaire sceptisé de
l'ONU
j'ai dit mais c'est qu'est-ce que vous
foutez là dans votre bureau alors que
les gens les goses sont sous-alimentés
que la corruption ravage la distribution
de la nourriture
que tout le monde le sait et qu'est-ce
que vous faites ? me dit "Ah, on ne fait
rien, peut rien faire parce que nos
accords avec les Grecs donne au Grecs la
compétence exclusive de la distribution
de la nourriture de la nourriture. Donc
le commissaire se cache derrière le
principe de subsidiarité dans une
condition dans une condition tout à fait
effroyable. Il était lui-même à l'espace
l'année dernière.
en 19 et a dit c'est une situation
abominable, inhumaine, les rats, les les
montagnes de détritus, une hygiène qui
rend les gens malades, absence d'eau
suffisante, absence de nourriture. Mais
il ne fait rien et je l'attaque ici
et je l'attaque dans ce livre.
On on va parler de Erdogan. Erdogan qui
dit
il y a pas d'excuses pour le commissaire
maintenant. Erdogan Erdogan qui dit
"Vous allez prendre votre part du
fardeau".
Oui.
En disant ça aux européens et en ouvrant
ses frontières, est-ce qu'il anticipe
encore un afflux massif de réfugiés chez
lui et qui dégaze
pour pouvoir éviter d'avoir trop de
pression sur son territoire ou c'est
légitime de dire aux Européens
maintenant vous prenez votre part du
fardeau ?
Bah légitime ou pas légitime ? Moi moi
j'ai aucune aucun respect, aucune amitié
pour Erdogan parce qu'il fait au kurde
parce que l'horreur de ces de sa guerre
qu'il a mené à Cobané et cetera contre
les enclaves Kurdes qui étaient
exemplires comme démocratie comme comme
société à PC. Donc j'ai aucune
j'ai aucune sympathie pour ce dictateur
turc.
Mais
la situation est est celle-là.
Maintenant, il a ouvert les frontières.
Les gard turc n'intér plus les gardesc
turc n'intér plus les zodiaques qui
partent de la région d'ITMIR donc de
l'autre côté de l'Espost Samos kios de
l'eros et cetera des des des îles dans
la mergée
au nord. Il laisse partir, il il convoie
par le pas il laisse partir
les bus de l'APK de de son parti
vont dans les camps, remplissent
[grognement] les bus, les transportent à
la frontière grecque.
Bon,
ce qui est essentiel, c'est des êtres
humains comme vous et moi qui putent sur
un mur militaire d'une police grecque
armée par l'Union européenne,
extraordinairement agressif, qui blesse,
qui frappe, qui se souvent tire très
proche de la tête des gens
et des dizaines de milliers de personnes
comme vous et moi enfants, comme mes
petits enfants et cetera. et sont
refoulés vers les gens les champs
enneigés de la frontière de l'évros et
et dorment des nuits à ciel ouvert
sur des terres sur la terre mouillée
privé de privé de soins médicaux privé
un désespoir total com comment on peut
faire ça aux hommes qui est responsable
l'Union européenne qui ferme les
frontières OK. Le le est-ce que tu as
quand quand tu étais à Lesbos, est-ce
que tu as été discuté du côté grec avec
les habitants des des îles pour
comprendre leur leur
leur agacement, leur énervement, leur
leur tout ça ?
Oui, j'ai beaucoup beaucoup discuté avec
les gens de Mitilini et je dois dire
c'est vrai, il y en a qui sont agacés
mais en général
il a la solidarité. le peuple grec enfin
le peuple grec la population ceux c'est
pas
trop ce qu'on a vu là
non ceux attends ceux de la population
de mile que j'ai vu dans les bistro ou
dans les organisations les avocats qui
travaillent pour les réfugiés qui sont
payés par les sociétés civiles
allemandes par médico international par
amnistie parlum et cetera et cetera
c'est tout à fait particulier l'espace
entre 1919 et 1922, une guerre
effroyable a eu lieu en Asie mineur où
il y avait beaucoup des millions et des
millions de Grecs. L'armée grecque a
lutté contre les kemalistes, contre les
troupes tataturques
qui qui ont succédé au sultana après la
convention, l'accord de Lausanne. des
Grecs ont perdu et 2 millions de Grecs
ont été refoulés vers de la Grec de la
Grèce
parce que la guerre a été perdue.
Beaucoup beaucoup de victimes par les
Grecs, par l'année grecque
à l'espace plus de 60 % des 100000
habitants sont descendants de réfugiés.
Alors vous prenez 22, ils sont arrivés
en 22 transporté en Grèce et vous prenez
aujourd'hui ça ça fait 100 ans. 100 ans
c'est trois générations. C'est un temps
mémoriel très court. N'importe quel
psychiatre vous dira c'est un temps
mémoire. Dans 60 % pratiquement de la
population grecque, il y a un
grand-père, une grand-mère réfugié.
Donc ça crée
une bienveillance. Ça crée une
compréhension, ça crée une solidarité
de beaucoup beaucoup de Grecs des îles
avec les réfugiés ou par exemple les
pêcheurs grecs
des îles
qui risquent leur vie continuellement.
souvent il y a j'ai été j'ai vu des
vidéos, j'ai eu des récits les les
pêcheurs grecs pour secourir des
réfugiés naufragés la nuit ou en pleine
tempête.
Donc il y a une sorte lumière dans cette
nuit d'horreur qui est l'espace. Ça
c'est politique de l'Union européenne de
terreur, de refoulement, de dissuasion
violente et réfugié. C'est l'attitude de
beaucoup beaucoup de Grecs, des îles de
bienveillance, de solidarité. Une autre
lumière, c'est l'engagement de beaucoup
d'ONG européennes, y compris françaises,
y compris françaises auprès des réfugiés
qui sont là, qui sont poursuivis par
Frontex, qui sont poursuivis par
l'organisation militaire de l'Union
européenne s'il sauve du naufrage un
zodiaque ou une embarcation frê. Mais ça
aussi il faut le dire les ONG des jeunes
européens français allemands italiens et
cetera, Amnesty International, Médico
International
euh Simad et cetera et cetera qui sont
sur place et qui font ce qu'ils peuvent
pour
aider les réfugiés
aider contre le naufrage et ensuite
quand ils sont sur terre de de maintenir
des rapports humains avec ces gens qui
sont traités comme des animaux.
Il y a Emmanuel Macron hier qui a qui a
fait un tweet qui a dit "Pleine
solidarité avec la Grèce et la Bulgarie,
la France est prête à contribuer aux
efforts européens pour leur prêter une
assistance rapide et protéger les
frontières. Nous devons agir ensemble
pour éviter une crise humanitaire
émigratoire."
Qu'est-ce que tu peux dire Emmanuel
Macron ? Il se f il se fout un peu de
notre gueule. Il fait un beau petit
tweet pour dire "Vous inquiétez pas les
Grecs, on va vous envoyer du pognon
comme ça vous pourrez faire des murs
plus grands." Euh avec une petite couche
de vernis social du genre, je reprends
sa phrase, "Nous devons agir ensemble
pour éviter une crise humanitaire et
migratoire".
On sent le côté un petit peu miel sucré
sur la fin quand même, non ? Bah non, je
non. Bah je connaissais pas cette cette
énoncé de du président de la République,
mais ce qu'il dit euh bah c'est la
raison même.
Le test maintenant, est-ce que la France
qui s'est couché devant Merkel en 2015
quand l'accord avec Erdogan a été fait
Hollande était lamortable ? il a il a
pas protesté rien. Il a il a accepté cet
accord dont on peut parler et dont
Erdogan seise maintenant
euh se réclame maintenant. Le test va
être si le président de la République
française parce que la France c'est
quand même la deux
puissance enfin je sais pas n'importe
quoi c'est
puissance de moyenne impuissance
non c'est
un siège au conseil de sécurité
la la 6e puissance économique du monde
la 2e d'Europe non la France c'est une
grande puissance et puis une très
démocrati Ça c'était à ton époque ça ?
Regarde la France au 21e siècle, on a
même plus de masque pour finir pour pour
donner aux médecins généralistes pour
qu'ils soient en première ligne contre
le corona coronavirus.
Ça je ne sais pas. Donc c'est ça c'est
une légende urbaine que tu vement
je peux plus venir à Paris dramatique
plus pour médecin. Non, il faut savoir
maintenant si le président Macron à
Bruxelles
va plaider pour la suppression des
subventions
au gouvernement protasciste raciste de
l'Europe orientale qui refuse
l'application du plan de redistribution
des vont faire le fait.
Ouais.
Chapeau. S'il le fait pas, il faut le
critiquer.
Il fera jamais.
Mais comment tu sais ? Bah parce qu'il
le fera jamais si on arrête si on arrête
de subventionner les États mendiants
comme tu les appelles pour qu'il fassent
le sale boulot, c'est-à-dire ériger des
barbelés, mettre des murs et pour qu'on
on soit on soit en France, en Europe, en
Allemagne, au Portugal tranquillement et
pas voir la misère du monde. Qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont faire ces États ? Ces États
mord, ils vont simplement faire un trou
comme Erdogan et rapprocher la ligne de
front plus près de Macron.
Non,
non,
non. Bah, il y a quand même des lois à
bon
le plan de relocalisation c'est
d'attribution de temps de réfugiés selon
le le PP plus le le bassin
démographique.
C'était la société la diplomatie
multilatérale européenne qui a négocié
ce plan de relocation qui est un
documentant normatif.
La Tquie, la Pologne, l'ongrie tout de
suite ont dit on n'accepte pas ce plan.
La Commission est allée devant la Cour
de justice européenne et la Cour de
justice européenne a dit ce document est
normativement
exécutoire, c'est-à-dire on doit s'y
plier.
Exécutire, il est exécutoire.
Les racistes, les gouvernements racistes
d'Europe occidentale orientale ont
refusé
d'accepter ce jugement.
Alors, on a espéré parce que le 26 mai
dernier les il y a eu les élections
européennes, une nouvelle commission est
née, un nouveau parlement, une nouvelle
commission est née qui a succédé à la
commission de Yuner qui a mis en œuvre
la stratégie de la terreur dans la
merge.
Et on a espéré, moi j'étais parmi ceux
là que la nouvelle commission et
notamment la présidente madame van
derlen a changé de politique aller
supprimer suspendre au moins
temporairement les subventions en 363,8
milliards d'euros, hein. C'est ce que le
fond de
combien combien de milliards ? 63,4
milliards en 3 ans qu'ont reçu les h
pays de l'Europe orientale qui refusent
de reçoir des réfugiés. Si on le métro,
je prends un exemple, le métro de
Budapest a été élargi, rénové
complètement par les fonds directs de
l'Union européenne par exemple, été les
infrastructures en Pologne, les
infrastructures en Rouvanie, en
Bulgarie, en Tchéquie, en Slovénie, en
Slovaquie ont été financés et sont
continués à être financés par l'Union
européenne. suspendre ces financements
pendant quelques temps
ramènerait à la raison certainement ces
gouvernements protascistes racistes de
l'Europe orientale. Or, il faut exiger
ça. Et le président Macron encore une
fois qui n'est pas président du pas
sousante mais qui est président de la
France, de la grande puissance de la
France peut obtenir peut obtenir la
suspension la suspension par Bruxelles
des paiements
au
gouvernement qui refuse et avec quel
argument je répète je me répète souvent
c'est ça doit être la vieillesse mais je
je répète
Ce que je dis dans mon livre, le premier
ministre polonais dit "Nous n'acceptons
pas de réfugier parce que nous devons
sauvegarder la pureté ethnique de la
Pologne. Il parle comme un nazis. C'est
un vocabulaire nazi. Si on tolère ça
dans le silence
en camouflant dans un dialogue
diplomatique, poli et cetera, des
attitude pareilles, et bien l'Europe est
entangée. L'Europe est entangée. Bon, je
je te coupe et là on va se la faire
entre toi et moi, d'accord ?
Ouais, c'est bon de me couper.
Je [raclement de gorge] sais mais là je
je t'ai pas je t'ai pas coupé beaucoup
cette fois-ci. Non.
Ah, tu avais je sentais une tendance là
coup
d'avance. Désolé. Euh, on l'a fait entre
nous là. Euh on a un continent européen
qui est coincé. Économiquement parlant,
ça commence à chauffer. Les classes les
plus pauvres se font paupériser. On a
les gilets jaunes en France depuis plus
d'un an, des gens qui ont plus rien dans
leur frigo, des gens qu'on a appelé les
100 sends. On a un peu près partout ça
en Europe. La montée des populismes se
base sur des gens qui ont du mal à
manger ou qui ont du mal à vivre. On est
d'accord Jean ? On est d'accord. Donc
là-dessus, là-dessus, on on a euh les
répercussions du réchauffement
climatique, les répercussion des
multiguerres en Irak, en Afghanistan,
Syrie, au Soudan, tout ça, on on est en
train de voir l'addition se pointer à
nos frontières aussi avec une économie
qui est pas très très stable.
On a des des des gouvernements qui se
rédissent parce que leur socle
d'électeur,
bah mal informés, ne comprend pas ce qui
se passe, sans empathie, sans
bienveillance sont en train de se
rédire. Est-ce que tu penses pas qu'on
est vraiment vraiment coincé là, que ça
va pas se régler gentiment avec des
belles idées de on va couper les
subventions de machin, ça suffit.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire là ? Là, il
faut du concret. les les subventions, ce
sera dans des années, le temps que ça ça
se joue avec le langage mielleux,
diplomatique de je fais pas c, je vais
pas faire ça, c'est compliqué.
Jean ?
Oui, mais ah il faut pas me pousser dans
dans le coin de l'idéaliste qui fait
je me fais la gymnasque ciel bleu. C'est
pas ça. J'ai fait j'argumente d'une
façon tout à fait concrè
concrète il faut
redistribuer les réfugiés normativement
obligatoirement
selon les critères qu'on a dit
de façon proactive. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait
sur les et les intégrer ? Ensuite, on
est des cours de Europe, des
apprentissages, les loger convenablement
et cetera et cetera. L'Allemagne en
2015-26 a a accueilli 1,2 million et
bien de ce 1,2 million plus de 70 % ont
du travail maintenant
par plus ou moins l'allemand euh sont
intégrés dans des villages. Moi, j'ai
voyagé aussi en Allemagne puisque le
livre est traduit en allemand. en
Bavière par exemple, j'étais dans des
villages de Bavière qui est le land
de la République fédérale allemande,
peut-être le plus conservateur
catholique noir qu'on puisse imaginer.
Et bien tes communes ont intégré
normalement dans les écoles, dans le
processus du travail des dizaines et des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés. Ça
fonctionne très très bien en France. Ça
fonctionne également bien. Alors, il
faut pas dire j'ai un je suis pour les
gilets jaunes. C'est magnifique cette
insurrection et j'espère qu'elle
continue et qu'elle s'amplifie.
Évidemment, les salaires moyens sont
beaucoup trop bas en France. L'inégalité
sociale est totalement scandaleuse.
Le contrôle de la presse quotidienne et
hebdomadaire par quelques trois ou
quatre oligarques. C'est un scandale et
un danger vivante pour la démocratie.
Tout ça,
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord avec
vous.
Mais fermer les frontières dire on peut
on a des problèmes, on a du chômage. Tu
as des baisses en France, on a du
chômage, on a des
On a une baisse en France du chômage.
Non non,
un peu
on a on a un traficotage de chômage.
On est on est en
c'est un c'est d'un autre ordre comme
dirait Pascal. Pascal disent c'est d'un
autre ordre. Là, il s'agit de gens
persécutés,
torturés chez eux, qui atteignent une
frontière européenne et qui demande
protection, qui demande vie.
Alors, à ce niveau, on peut pas leur
opposer les les les salaires
insuffisants en France. Non, il y a eu
un devoir d'humanité prioritaire total,
radical. Qu'est-ce que tu penses des
gens qui disent voilà il faut arrêter
les haut spots, du moins les g les boss
ainsi de suite
et refaire des camps d'intégration
sur leur espace frontalier, c'est-à-dire
reconstruire des camps un peu plus
propres.
Non, il faut pas de camp, il faut
distribuer les réfugiés. Je le dis pour
la 5e fois mais tu m'écoutes pas. Faut
distribuer les réfugiés selon le plan
négocié qui est là de relocalisation
parmi les 27 pays membres de ce
continent.
Financer l'intégration enfit pour
intégrer dans la société telle qu'elle
est ses réfugiés. Mais l'idée, je le
répète, l'idée de l'Union européenne qui
fait une première analyse qui est juste.
D'ailleurs, il y a une instance de
l'Union européenne dont on parle jamais
puisqu'elle est quasi secrète. Tous les
deux mois, les ministres de la justice
et de l'intérieur des 27 se réunissent
se réunissent et font des
recommandations à la commission. Et
c'est vrai, moi j'ai discuté un peu avec
les gens de Bruxelles que ce conclave
semi-se
des ministres de l'intérieur et de la
justice T27 a une influence très très
forte sur la commission.
Ils sont inquiets pour des questions de
terrorisme
hein.
Ils sont inquiets pour des questions de
terrorisme.
Ils sont inquiets pour la question de
terrorisme mais l'influence qu'ils ont
sur la commission, ils disent à la
commission préservez-nous des réfugiés.
fait qu'il y a plus de réfugiés ou le
moins possible de réfugiés qui arrivent
parce que s'il y a plus de réfug les
réfugiés continue arriver et bien ça
nourrit le discours xénophobe des forces
racistes dans notre pays de madame Le
Pen de Salvini de l'AFT et cetera et
cetera.
Or là il y a une erreur totale. C'est
vrai. Non je vais prendre un exemple. Je
prends un exemple. C'est vrai que la
théorie du boumis est politiquement très
rentable. Hitler l'a fait dans les
années 30, madame Le Pen le fait,
Saluini le fait. Saluini d'une façon
très euh très explicite. Il dit aux
Italiens, "Vous avez du chômage, vous
allez mal, euh il y a des salaires bas,
vous avez de la peine à boucler leur
moi. Qui est responsable ? et bien c'est
ces réfugiés de Lampedousa de Malte et
cetera qui arrivent. La théorie
du bou émisire qui est une théorie
totalement détestable sans aucun
fondement parce que c'est pas le réfugié
qui est responsable des problèmes
économiques en France, en Allemagne et
ailleurs. Enfin ces théories du bouquire
utilisé par l'extrême droite depuis
toujours sur ce continent est
politiquement rentable. L'erreur totale,
je le répète, de la commission de
Bruxelles est de l'accepter ces théorie,
de de faire un pas en direction des
mouvements xénophobes, de dire il faut
apaisser ces mouvements xénophobes, il
faut freiner leur progression électorale
qui est inquiétant, d'accord, qui est
inquiétant et qui est permanent depuis
quelques années. Il faut freiner la
progression électorale et l'influence
politique de ces mouvements xénophobes
en réduissant en leur donnant des gages
en leur donnant des gages en faire un
pas en leur direction en violant le
droit d'accile en liquidant le droit
d'accile en refusant devant des
frontières fermées les persécuter qui
demandent la vie la protection
la la la la la survie c'est une erreur
fondamentale. On a compris.
Oui, mais je le répète, tu tu me tu n'as
pas compris parce que tu me répètes
toujours la même chose. Je dis la
commission fait là
une faute
totale avec un raciste, un antisémite,
un antiislamique, un antiféministe, avec
un raciste, on ne peut pas discuter.
C'est un ennemi de l'humanité, il faut
le combattre. Point à la
question d'internet de Thba. N'est-il
pas paradoxal de dénoncer une oligarchie
avec leurs agendas et et d'espérer que
ces derniers agissent d'une façon
urbaniste pour les migrants ?
Je te répète la question.
Oui. Non, elle est juste, je veux dire,
mon livre tombe. C'est c'est mauvais
signe ça. C'est le mauvais signe. Non,
la question est tout à fait juste. Il
faut combattre de l'écarchie. Il faut il
faut rétablir la démocratie. Ça c'est
deux combats complémentaires si tu veux.
C'est évident. Euh il faut pas attendre
que l'olérarchie tout à coup se
convertisse au bien commun, à l'intérêt
général, au respect des droits de
l'homme. Ça n'arrivera jamais.
Bah les révolutionnaires des 1789
euh ils sont pas allé voir le roi à
Mersailles demandant qu'il donne du
pain. Ça ils ont pris la Bastie, la
fortest du roi, l'ont brûlé, l'ont
détruit. Ils sont
marchés ensuite sur l'étulerie en août.
Ils sont pris les thuleries. Le roi
s'est enfuit. On l'a ramené finalement,
on l'a tué. On a
on a proclamé la République
et les révolutionnaires français ont
changé l'histoire du monde. L'histoire
du monde. Pratiquement toutes les
Républiques, les constitutions, y
compris la constitution suisse de 1848
sont des copies de la Constitution de la
première République française. Donc il
faut pas attendre
euh
même
cette illustoire d'attendre que
l'oligarchie par elle-même
a laisse
renonce à la tyrannie qu'elle impose au
monde et à ses profits pharamineux
pharamineux. Vous savez qui est le
l'homme le plus riche de la terre ?
Bousos de l'Amazon, il a 148
milliards de dollars
où il y a un rapport de l'Oxfamme de de
l'organisation non gouvernementale
anglaise de décembre 2018 qui dit que
les h
plus puissants milliardaires du monde
les h plus puissants milliardaires du
monde ont tu ont autant de patrimoine
autant d'avoirs patrimoniaux autant de
fortune d'argent que 2,7
milliards d'êtres humains, c'est-à-dire
la partie la plus pauvre de l'humanité.
Par ces gens vont pas, l'histoire nous
le montre, vont pas sans violence, sans
insurrection renoncer à ses profits
pharamineux, à cette position
d'extraordinaire arbitraire de richesse
de tyrannie.
Bah, il faut que les hommes, les femmes,
les adolescents se lèvent, brisent leur
pouvoir, brisent et l'histoire montre
que ça s'est fait,
que c'est possible.
On ar on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Est-ce que tu as trois livres
à conseiller à la communauté ?
À part le mien,
je peux le montrer.
Et deux autres.
Deux autres.
tout à fait différent quand le souvenir
quand les souvenirs viennent à moi
de voyard d'être carin
morin certainement
et le livre sur le populisme
de Rosan Wallot édition du Seuil
c'est des livres utiles
qui nourrissent la conscience et qui la
rendent capable de se battre.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
C'est terrible.
Non, on a posé la même question à Fidel
Castro juste avant sa mort. Effectif que
et Philidel Castro a simplement répondu
: "Dites-leur que je les envie.
Dites-leur que je les ai envie.
J'approche du bout de ma vie.
Les jeunes générations sont là et
portent l'espérance.
Et ce que je voudrais leur dire, c'est
pour les Européens hein, si on était à
Pékin ou à Honduras, ce serait
différent. Mais un jeune français avec
tous les droits et libertés publiques
qu'il a, il peut changer le monde. Il
peut changer le monde. Il n'y a pas
d'impuissance
en démocratie. nos ancêtres ont lutté
pour ses droits. Le droit de grève, euh
les le droit de de l'insurrection, c'est
le bonheur des hommes comme dit la la
Constitution américaine de 1776.
Euh [gémissement]
The right to happiness, le droit au
bonheur pour tous pour ce combat, y
compris pour des réfugiés. Pour ce
combat là, il faut se lever, il faut se
battre tous les jours.
Jean Zigler, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]